weil ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen
minecraft map spotlight und zwar von
einer minecraft map die tetris bilder
haltet ihr seht schon da ist ein
riesiger kaufen
der ist auch hier so ein bisschen in die
länge gezogen und da sind auch ein paar
komische sachen bildchen und so das ist
interessiert sei als nicht denn ihr
findet ihn downloading in der
beschreibung das ganze selbst
ausprobieren aber ich würde ich jetzt
nur ganz kurz zeigen wie das ganze
funktioniert und was man damit machen
kann weil das ist echt cool und das ist
auf jeden fall echt cool
wir sehen hier schon verschiedene
buttons hier finden wir einmal einen
instructions button dann finden wir
einen start button einen reset button
und eine news background on more
difficult button
wenn wir auf den instructions button
drücken bekommen wir ein buch in diesem
buch steht
damit haben wir jetzt quasi die regel
bestätigt das ganze aber relativ
scheißegal ich hab da vorne schon so ein
paar andere instructions hingeschmissen
hiermit können wir das ganze auf
entweder oder oft machen das ist uns
aber auch erst mal relativ egal weil ich
einfach nur tetris spielen will wie
gesagt ihr könnt das alles selbst
herausfinden denn ich habe vorhin schon
ein spiel gespielt da könnt ihr dann
einfach auf reset drücken rettet sich
das ganze und wir können das ganze dann
jetzt mal spiele da drücken weiter auf
start und lädt schon da kommt jetzt ein
block nach unten ich kann es nach rechts
laufen dann mach ich dir nach rechts ist
schon dass da unten blick jetzt oder ich
kann nach links laufen dann ist das
ganze links so dieses quick drop
das muss ich nicht wegschmeißen oder ich
muss einfach rechtsklick drücken dann
verschwindet das ganz kurz und ist jetzt
wieder unten
ihr seht jetzt auch schon jetzt das ist
jetzt auch schon ich habe diesen gelben
dieses gelbe quadrat quasi was vorhin
rechts da eingeblendet wurde
und das ist jetzt das nächste also dax
hat jetzt wieder rechts wieder unten
so jetzt bekomme ich dementsprechend
wieder das grüne so und diese teile hat
sich ja nein natürlich kriegt ob gemacht
ich wollte das rotieren rotieren geht
nämlich wenn man mit space einmal hoch
springt dann rotiert sich das ganze
aber egal leute ich schaffe das ich
mache das ganze schafft das wieder soll
es muss ich nur noch dieses dieses teil
da vorne muss jetzt irgendwie dazwischen
bekommen
ich mache das einfach so ich weiß nicht
ob das darunter schieben kann so wie bei
den ganz alten täter ist dagegen dass
immer noch da hat man so ein bisschen
gewartet bis es ganz unten an und es war
ganz schnell zur seite gehen und dann
hat uns darunter dazwischengeschoben ich
hoffe mal das funktioniert jetzt so
kommt kommt kommt funktioniert so das
gleiche machen wir jetzt auch hier wird
das heißt ich gehen damit erst mal hier
hin wenn ihr tetris nicht kennt also ich
muss das ganze hier sollte tetris kennen
das stelle ich mal außer frage
ihr solltet es eigentlich wirklich
kennen ich muss das quasi alles zubauen
und immer wenn eine reihe zu shh nein
ich mache das so ich hier den und stelle
hier in das viel besser dann habe ich
die erste reihe schon mal für dich
nein das war scheiße aber jetzt habe ich
zum beispiel schon 40 prozent jetzt
rechts am rand und ihr seht links an
diesem holz ding das soll seine 1
darstellen also das soll darstellen dass
ich quasi im ersten level mich noch
befinde so das mache ich jetzt mal so
ich denke ihr habt das spielprinzip
verstand ich werde ich kenne das
jahrelang so weiter spielen ich liebe
tetris einfach auf dem handy das ist
einzel einzigen spiele zusammen mit
doodle jump die ich seit jahren darauf
habe weil es echt richtig richtig spaß
macht also ich weiß es der iphone app
davon gibt ich weiß nicht wie das ganze
mit poetisch soll jedenfalls ich denke
das spielprinzip verstanden den hier
will ich jetzt zum beispiel ganz andere
ansätze hier
dann könnte ich wieder den rob button
drücken dann werde der kampf konnten
den würde ich jetzt so wichtig bin setze
ich glaube ich mit dem ich glaube ich
wird dem hier noch mal springen noch mal
springen könnt ihn halt so aufdrehen wie
ihr wollt so dann würde ich den glaube
ich hier hinsetzen der unsere andere
spanier dahin allerdings wenn jetzt sagt
ich hab keinen bock mehr seht ihr hier
im board game und da steht auch im board
game
das heißt wir können jetzt richtig drauf
machen dann steht ihr games in progress
klick hier to confirm that they will
muss ich klicke hier drauf passiert nix
blabla wir müssen nämlich gehen und dann
einfach klick hier dann bist du drauf
klicken und dann steht der reset in das
ganze doch normal wenn wir wollen und
jetzt diesem background what i möcht ich
auch mal zeit habe ich das jetzt an
gemacht und jetzt ist das ganze ein
bisschen schwieriger also ihr seht schon
das
geht alles es geht zwar nicht schneller
aber ihr seht im hintergrund dass dieser
ganze background quasi farbig ist und
das ist halt dementsprechend dass das
manchmal für verwirrung sorgen haben
wenn jetzt gerade zwar noch nicht aber
am ende dass ihr dann denkt so habe ich
das schon stein gesetzt oder nicht
bleibt ist für alles ein bisschen nicht
so krass schwer aber auf jeden fall
erhöhte den schwierigkeitsgrad und ich
finde auf jeden fall leute ihr müsst das
ganze mit einem daumen hoch auf jeden
fall belohnen wenn ihr das gefällt dass
ich möchte sich vorgestellt habe und ihr
müsst auf jeden fall in die beschreibung
klickt euch das ganze downloaden das ist
in minecraft forum
ich spiele es in der version 14 23 b ich
glaube es geht in jeder 1.8 wir sind
also in jedem neuen snapshot ich würde
aber trotzdem einfach den leichtesten
den ich jetzt auch hier genommen habe
und dann würde ich sagen ich wünsche
euch viel viel spaß bei tetris schreibt
mir nochmal oder ihr könnt mir ja mal
videos machen tetris video wenn ihr das
ganze schnell abgespielt hat und dann
was eure highscores also ist wie sonst
würde ich sagen das war es auch schon
von mir ich wollte ich das ganze nur
schnell vorstellen weil es richtig
richtig geile game app ist nochmal die
sachen nach rechts gehen dann geht das
weg gibt der blog nach rechts nach links
geht aber nach links hoch springen und
das ganze rotiert sich also das dreht
sich im kreis und kriegt ob einmal
richtig machen und das feld direkt
runter ich möchte jetzt auch nicht viel
weiter reden weil ihr werk das schon
meine stimme ist einfach total im eimer
ich bin immer noch erkältet ich weiß
jetzt dass eine chronisch erkältung ist
oder ob ich ihn allergie habe oder
irgendwie sowas muss noch mal zum arzt
gehen bleibt bei instagram schon gesehen
als ich habe mein abitur haben abitur
schreiben alle herzlich glückwunsch klar
ich bin so ein studienplatz als möglich
ist auch egal leute die kommentare
diese verabschiedung sind man so scheiße
letzter zeit